this video was brought to you by
playstation
it's winter in marvel's new york but if
you're expecting the cold to keep the
villains at home then we're guessing
you're unfamiliar with spider-man
one year after peter parker triumphed
over the demons doc ock and hammerhead
new threats have emerged to bring a new
era of fear
into the city with sable international's
rather
heavy-handed attitude to security now a
distant memory
and norman osborne nowhere to be seen
energy company roxon has stepped in as
the latest
morally dubious organization to make its
mark on nyc
on the surface all seems well roxon has
pioneered an experimental clean energy
source called new form which it claims
can power the whole city
however i'm pretty sure most energy
providers don't have branded armed
guards in exosuits
well not any that we know of anyway that
said it seems
roxanne has a pretty good reason to
invest in heavy security a criminal
organization
known as the underground has its sights
set on new form
and they're not in any mood to ask for
it politely
we're after the new form ignore
everything else
led by the tinkerer whose identity
remains a mystery
the underground members are immediately
identifiable by the neon purple glow of
their high-tech armor and weaponry
the nature of the tech and the source of
its power remains a mystery as well
but it can generate portable shields and
temporarily enhance the strength of its
wearer
which is something miles discovers
firsthand
if this spectacular skirmish is anything
to go by the underground and roxanne's
destructive rivalry is going to shake
the foundations of marvel's new york
throw the prowler into the mix 2 as
confirmed by this variant cover for
amazing spider-man number 55 and it's
clear that miles is going to have his
hands
extremely full and that's not even
taking into account the other super
villains miles could run into
in true spider-man fashion every
criminal peter parker has encountered in
the first game
is down but certainly not out
we already know that miles gets his
rematch with the mighty rhino
this time on far more even footing but
what of the rest of the sinister six
as far as we know electro vulture
scorpion mr negative
and doc ock are still a guest of honor
at the raft but if their
supposedly impregnable security has been
breached by rhino
what's to say a jailbreak isn't in the
cards
there's also the iconic baddies that
peter dealt with prior to us taking
control of him
as indicated by some of the collectibles
found in marvel's spider-man
there's also a vial of dr kirk connor's
blood which reveals that the lizard is
still
on the loose in marvel's new york we
also know that greens of the sandman are
currently contained in another vial
and based on several pieces of evidence
that peter parker has previously come up
against mysterio
and let's not forget about norman
osborne who
in his desperate hunt for a cure to stop
his son harry's degenerative genetic
disease
has developed a creepy black symbiote
known as
gr35 and when we think creepy black
symbiote we think
well you know part of the thrill of any
spider-man game is discovering
which of the many villains that have
battled him over the years
will make an appearance and in what guys
with fascinating new takes on the
tinkerer and prowler already confirmed
we can't wait to see what other clever
twists on the classic bad guys insomniac
games has lined up